en compétition sportive proprement dit
que le championnat de france de monoski
à chamrousse organisée par la fédération
française de ski avec les débuts
fulgurants d'une jeune raphaël peggy 15
ans et demi qui remporte l'épreuve
devant l'ex championne de france ô de
pakala chez les garçons hervé manas dans
le mono ce qui existe depuis 10 ans déjà
mais reste une discipline relativement
nouvelle en compétition alors si vous
voulez devenir savant sur le monoski et
brillant société écoutez les
explications de christian durand
leurs présidents s'appellent tard zones
qui sont pour nous les reptiles
d'orsières les mercenaires des deux
alpes les tabous d'avoriaz les
bootleggers de grenoble il est sûr
qu'une banane à deux lions les bobos
l'homme de saint gervais et les kitambo
de serre chevalier c'est la tribu des
monos ski des alpes un microcosme des
copains qui depuis dix ans se retrouve
sur les pistes
ça s'est passé dans les premières
courses on s'est retrouvé un petit peu
par band c'est à dire une bande qui
venait d'une station une bande qui est
juste de nos stations et ses bonbons se
donner des noms c'est un peu des noms
guerre si tu préfères pouvoir s'opposer
face aux compétitions mais bon à cette
époque là tu est pas la compet pour la
compacte
depuis trois ans la fédération française
de ski organise un championnat
une formule originale un slalom
parallèle couru simultanément par deux
concurrents sur deux pistes a collées
l'une à l'autre tu sens des muscs
épisodes avant le débat allait encore
l'épreuve est de type de gymkhana le
parcours comporte des champs de bosses
des sauts sur un ou plusieurs tremplins
et trois bosses en dos d'âne
concurrent reçoit des pénalités s'ils
tombent mais peut également se voir
bonifié de plusieurs secondes
s'il exécute des figures une seconde
pour un twist une seconde ou deux
secondes pour à simple ou double gratot
de seconde pour ajout de tristes et 4
secondes par un hélicoptère
aujourd'hui c'est moins 1 g - 1 pour le
blog un championnat pour la compétition
oui mais surtout l'occasion pour une
bande d'initié de copains de se
rencontrer et de se faire plaisir
ensemble le plaisir des yeux
pour les autres le plaisir de la glisse
pour
et en football